oh I was thinking about this that I have
a prediction that that Hillary Clinton
is going to end up running against
Donald Trump's and here's what's gonna
happen because Joe Biden's is really I
mean he's disappeared I don't know he
just he's aging quickly it seems like
and if he's not then I believe it's
being made to look like he is right so
if he is physically unable to run which
can happen they the delegates the the
muffets I don't know this part but the
Democratic Party I don't know who I
don't know exactly how but this is true
that the Democratic Party can put up a
new candidate they can just say oh he's
too sick you know he can say I'm too
sick I can't do it I can for whatever
reason and then at the last minute they
can but this is our candidate so I have
a feeling that that's what they're gonna
do that the Democratic Party's gonna
slip Hillary in there
the last second because it takes off the
road that's all that that beat down on
the road all that hard the you know the
um all you know Biden took that he took
all that that her motion he took all the
commotion that was going on and then he
kind of took all the bullets and then
Hillary gonna show up there at the last
second so I just have a feeling man
because if that that's a true thing like
I think Frank Franklin Roosevelt had had
done a couple of terms and then he was
too sick he was too sick I think to to
run it during like his last term or
something or when he was running for his
last term he was too sick to run and
they had a sub him out they basically
sub him out so you can people can be
subbed out and they don't have to go do
like a whole like everyone doesn't have
to vote again from there
and stuff like that they just uh the
delegates choose the delegates choose
like okay this is who we've decided boom
so just kind of wild but that's my
predictions man I predict that that's
gonna happen I just wanted to get that
out there um good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watches one